[Musica]
prossimi diciotto minuti il vostro
cervello verrà creato più e più volte in
solo due di queste non sarete voi a
farlo
ma c'è di più queste intrusioni non
avranno nulla a che fare con questioni
di tipo etico legale e di buona
educazione non necessiteranno di
autorizzazioni particolari o di domande
specifiche e non saranno visibili perché
accadendo qui dentro è difficile vederci
qualcosa o forse no
oggi con le nuove e raffinate tecniche
di neuroimaging funzionale è possibile
vedere e valutare un cervello e le sue
differenti funzionalità per fare questo
però in casa necessariamente di due cose
un cervello oggetto non scontato e
recentemente neanche così disponibile e
un scanner rm un oggetto che nemmeno
scontato avremmo potuto portare qui
dentro oggi per riuscire a vedere tutti
i vostri cervelli in attività perché il
cervello in attività qui dentro ne
abbiamo tanti ma manchiamo di uno
scanner
allora vi propongo un sistema per portar
fuori i vostri neuroni della vostra
scatola cranica e senza spargimento di
sangue per cortesia fatte così provate
ad allungare un braccio davanti a voi
ottimo
questa è una perfetta rappresentazione
di un neurone con il nucleo al centro
del vostro palmo le dita e dendriti
grigioni segnali dall'esterno li
processano lungo lasso né all'interno di
un centro di elaborazione saltate un po
la manica potete anche vedere la guaina
mielinica le cellule di schwann più o
meno pelose ma proviamo a vedere un po
meglio nel dettaglio questa meravigliosa
macchina come funziona e quindi vi
chiedo in questo momento di fare
esattamente quello che vi chiedo di fare
alzatevi tutti in piedi
allungate le due braccia davanti ad un
ottimo e così ci vediamo anche meglio
muovete le dita in questo modo
commovente eccole questi sono i neuroni
che stanno rispondendo ad una
stimolazione focale quella che io vi sto
comunicando e lo fanno in modo molto
rispondente e con nessuna morte
cerebrale in sala molto bene ora
continuate a fare esattamente quello che
vi dico di fare fermate le vostre dita
volgete le mani dorso contro dorso
alzate la mano destra prunetto da sotto
a sopra la mano sinistra con giungete i
palmi delle mani intrecciate le dita e
fate molta attenzione che il pollice
della mano sinistra sia la mano sinistra
quella che era sotto bravo la mano
destra ecco esatto sia presa tra il
pollice della mano destra e l'indice
della mano destra poi allungate gli
indici e stringete forte forte forte
i polpastrelli guardateli eccoli queste
sono due neuroni che stanno costruendo
una trasmissione sinaptica neuroni che
rispondono ad un segnale mentre altri
neuroni hanno appena subito il primo
attacco hacker che è andato a buon fine
se non riuscite a fare così
no
lui sono certo siete sicuri che sono
sicuro che avete immaginato di
rispondere a delle indicazioni che
provenivano da banti ai vostri pedate di
immagini che erano davanti ai vostri
occhi mentre i vostri neuroni
rispondevano ma forse non è proprio così
in effetti noi vediamo ciò che vogliamo
vedere quello che ci aspettiamo di
vedere mentre la nostra attenzione non
riesce a cogliere cose là dove avvengono
azioni e cambiamenti che passano sotto
la nostra soglia di consapevolezza
questo significa che noi reagiamo a
degli stimoli non tanto della realtà
oggettiva che arriva la nostra
percezione quanto ad un'immagine mentale
che ci costruiranno un'immagine mentale
che ci crea delle idee o appunto delle
immagini che mettono in comunicazione
qualcosa che sta fuori con qualcosa che
sta dentro e lavorano con qualcuno che
sta dal lato nostro o contro di noi
noi vediamo ciò che ci aspettiamo di
vedere significa che nella maggior parte
delle nostre scelte quotidiane siamo
liberamente obbligati ovvero pensiamo in
base a quello che già cretina momento ci
sentiamo liberi di governare il nostro
pensiero
il nostro sistema hackerato ha già preso
una decisione per noi mettendo lui in
relazione la realtà con la nostra mente
il nostro modo di relazionarci con la
realtà non passa sempre per il sentiero
più lineare logico e razionale che
possiamo immaginare quanto per dei
percorsi emotivi che sono caratterizzati
da euristiche e bari ass fallace
percettive e illusioni del nostro
pensiero
ma chi è che ci illude
sicuramente qualcuno che viene da fuori
o qualcosa che viene da fuori il mercato
le informazioni la pubblicità ma molto
spesso qualcosa che viene da dentro
in effetti la comunicazione ci può
ingannare ma anche la nostra mente mente
o meglio la nostra mente ci mente il
fatto è che noi affidiamo alla nostra
mente ciò che vogliamo fortemente
credere ma cosa significa credere
l'origine della parola credere ci
rimanda la parola credito
se noi abbiamo fiducia nella nostra
mente perché diamo credito ad essa e
allo stesso modo la stessa maniera se ci
fidiamo nella realtà è perché crediamo a
quella che essa ci rimanda
queste realtà in mente sono due delle
tre facce della medaglia
c'è poi quella che io chiamo la terza
faccia della medaglia
la terza fascia ovvero la terza meta è
quel luogo in cui noi siamo liberamente
obbligati nelle nostre decisioni e quel
luogo in cui noi spendiamo il nostro
credito relazionale non solo nelle
nostre relazioni economiche del nostre
relazioni umane essere obbligati libre
monti obbligati significa obbligati e
legati insieme o meglio la nostra mente
che ci obbliga che ci lega alle sue
proprie decisioni
facciamo un gioco prendete una penna e
un foglietto di carta che avete trovato
al rientro dalla pausa nella vostra
borsa grazie
come vedete questa è la parte più
articolata nella presentazione riuscire
a recuperare in quel sacco
la penna ottimo e un foglio di carta
qualsiasi colore ce la mette in mano
ora durante il gioco che vi propongo su
quel foglietto di carta
potete già iniziare a scrivere una lista
di 4 numeri in colonna in questo modo un
1 2 3 e 4
accanto a ciascun numero tra poco
scriverete una risposta molto rapida
quanto rapida e la domanda che io vi
farò prima però mettiamoci d'accordo su
quelle che sono le regole di questo
gioco come tutti i giochi ci sono delle
regole da rispettare prima regola per
cortesia quando individuerete la
risposta alla domanda nella vostra mente
tra scrivetela su quel foglio e poi alla
fine del gioco e vi dirò io quando gioco
finisce leggerete quella alcune risposte
senza modificare quanto scritto
la prima regola possiamo riassumere con
il non barate è chiara e chiara
seconda regola da questo momento in poi
non si possono più fare domande e chiaro
alla scuola regola sia una risposta
ottimo ci siamo terza regola è ultima da
questo momento in poi fino a quando
finirà questo gioco non si può più
ridere se qualcuno contravviene a una di
queste regole o più non è un problema
gira il foglio e lascia giocare gli
altri
ok iniziamo per cortesia rispondete a
questa domanda quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto scritto seconda domanda
quante sigarette ci sono in un pacchetto
di sigarette scritto
terza domanda quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto di sigarette intatto
pato quarta e ultima la domanda per
cortesia rispondete a questa domanda
quante sigarette ci sono in questo
pacchetto di sigarette
scritto
[Musica]
il gioco è finito potete ridere così ci
liberiamo di un po di ansia e
soprattutto potete ridere di gusto
adesso che vedrete quante volte la
vostra mente hackerato a se stessa
partiamo dalla prima domanda quante
sigarette ci sono in un pacchetto che
cosa avete risposto no non serve che me
lo diciate queste ma che nessuno dei
libri aperti di fronte a chi ve n'era
degli hacker cognitivi
tanto è vero che voi vi siete sentiti o
la maggior parte di queste sentita
libera di rispondere in modo generale a
questa domanda scrivendo numeri che
vanno da 0 a 20 un numero qualsiasi da 0
a 20 o risposta del tipo dipende non so
quante ne sono state fumate prima di
portarlo sul palco mentre eravate già
inconsapevolmente obbligati a costruire
una risposta da un'associazione tra
sigaretta e pacchetti di sigarette
il vostro sistema già attirato vi stava
tenendo lontano da una realtà seppur
verosimile è plausibile
infatti chi di voi la domanda quante
sigarette ci sono in un pacchetto ad
esempio pensato ad un pacchetto tipo
questo oppure ad un pacchetto tipo
questo alcuno è la dimostrazione più
vostro sistema era già stato creato da
quello che si chiama byas di conferma
seconda domanda quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto di sigarette
così ha scritto non serve rispondere
siete già stati hackerati giusto ve lo
ricordate qui il lungo i sentieri della
comunicazione liberamente obbligante
iniziata nell'elencazione delle tre
norme seppur paradossali come quella di
non ridere
e dalla prima domanda ecco che ha
costruito ha confermato quel inferenza
che se stiamo parlando di pacchetti di
sigarette poi cilic con addirittura di
pacchetti segrete beh allora mi sto
riferendo a proprio a te le immagini dei
pacchetti di sigarette
qualcuno di voi nella seconda domanda
quindi o la maggior parte di voi
ripetuto la risposta data la prima
oppure la leggermente aggiornata
aggiustata e quella che si chiama
euristica dell'ancoraggio e
dell'aggiustamento è la stessa che
funziona quando ad esempio c'è ancora
amo il primo prezzo comunicato in una
negoziazione commerciale oppure quando
cerchiamo un proviamoci insieme a
rispondere a questa domanda quanti sono
il muro più preciso possibile i migranti
extra europei che sono arrivati in
italia nel 2017 mentre state cercando
quel numero il vostro sistema hackerato
stalin tenendo lontana dalla vostra
risposta
bene ad esempio la raffigurazione di un
broker finanziario di zurigo che si
appena trasferata nella city di milano
oppure di uno chef stellato giapponese
extracomunitaria che ha trovato lavoro
stabile a roma
questi inferenza questo sistema
differente cresce ma noi si rinforza con
la terza domanda poi mi fate parliamo di
pacchetti intatti a cosa ci stiamo
riferendo che ci stiamo riferendo a
quell'esperienza che noi abbiamo di
pacchetti che abbiamo visto che abbiamo
vissuto
ecco allora che andiamo a cercare la
risposta o meglio il nostro hacker viola
i nostri sistemi in e monici scardina i
riferimenti della nostra esperienza e ci
fa scrivere numeri tipo 10 20 25 giusto
cioè pescando quello che è più
rappresentativo
quello che è più disponibile e memoria
si chiama euristica della disponibilità
vado a pescare la risposta laddove o un
vissuto particolare quindi potrei
rispondere 35 si sa sono appena tornato
ad esempio dall'australia e aiuti free
ho comprato un pacchetto intatto
incellophanato che contiene 35 sigarette
ma la questione è se io avessi risposto
19 avresti accettato questa risposta 19
sì se fosse disposto a spostare un po
più in là i limiti della mia esperienza
di riferimento per trovare una risposta
corretta la terza domanda riferendomi ad
esempio bea pacchetti di sigarette
legalmente venduti nelle tabaccherie di
londra ma veniamo alla quarta domanda
quante sigarette ci sono in questo
pacchetto di sigarette è possibile
trovare una risposta corretta giusta a
questa domanda oppure dopo che il nostro
sistema è stato hackerato questa
possibilità è svanita sfumata perché
perché in effetti lì su quel foglietto
di carta voi avete iniziato a confermare
un'immagine mentale che vi ha tenuti
lontano anche nel momento in cui ce
l'avevate di fronte agli occhi alla
realtà dei pacchetti di sigarette o
sbaglio rispondere in modo giusto alla
quarta domanda significa abbandonare
l'immagine mentale che ho dei pacchetti
di sigarette significa non ascoltare la
voce suadente che risponde senza nemmeno
guardarlo quel problema significa
riuscire a toglierci dall'ancora dei
nostri schemi mentali che sono
rappresentati oggi da quelle sedie ma
che ogni giorno sono rappresentate dalle
nostre modalità decisionali nelle quali
viviamo ed essere capaci di controllare
le violazioni e le intromissioni di
questi sistemi a caranti di queste
modalità di controllo della mente che
vengono da noi stessi e infatti la
nostra mente
che ci obbliga che ci rende liberamente
obbligati nelle nostre scelte
chi è il nostro comportamento che sta
sotto il rischio sempre più frequente di
essere atterrato da noi stessi molto di
più di quanto pensiamo noi conviviamo
con un arcade interna allora mi
piacerebbe che ci portassimo a casa da
questa esperienza tra sneakers tre
programmi che permettono al nostro caro
hacker non solo di essere più
consapevole dei propri limiti ma anche
di avere qualche strumento in più per
migliorare le nostre decisioni
quotidiane in campo relazionale umano in
campo economico sociale e in quello che
vi caratterizza di più nelle vostre
professionalità e nella vostra
quotidianità primo sneakers dubitare
delle informazioni così come vi sono
date dall esterno così come sono create
dall interno verificarle secondo smokers
valorizzare l'errore perché se è vero
che è la nostra mente che ci rende
liberamente obbligati beh almeno che lo
sia nella direzione un po più opportuna
sempre più opportuna e infine terzo
sneakers evitare di fumare
a ricordarci di non solo per la mente ma
di aprire anche tutti i pacchetti di
sigarette che ci troveremo di fronte
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]